hey it's chris we have four asian
americans making their own version of
curry and they're gonna try each other's
and rate them out of ten and we'll see
which one is the best hey i'm eric hi
i'm tiffy hey i'm randall hey what's up
i'm eugene i'm ethnically korean i grew
up eating all types of asian food
actually hawaii has a very very heavy
asian population so most of the food
there you're gonna see has some kind of
asian influence to it so i actually was
born in china i came here when i was
about three years old when i was growing
up i had a lot of different types of
food one of my favorites was always
japanese curry so i'm chinese and aloe
vera i was born and raised in new york i
grew up eating the smell asian food
until i started cooking curry wise yeah
growing up but then it's been a while
since i had curry i'm japanese and i
grew up in japan curry is one of my most
favorite food it seems simple but then
you could be really creative or you know
put something interesting i'm really
looking forward to seeing what other
people cooked i watched a lot of anime
when i was growing up and the curry and
anime always looked so good so what i
have here today is a very typical
japanese curry with potatoes carrots
some type of protein i use chicken a
serving of white rice i did put some
little extra secret ingredients in there
japanese people put minced apple to make
it taste a little bit different a little
bit sweeter so i'll be really impressed
if any of the other people can pick up
on what i put it looks like japanese
curry to me it looks pretty basic
the rice just like that i don't like how
he plays the rice
i think it's good it's simple the flavor
is there it's not too spicy which thank
god because i can't handle spice kind of
reminds me of like curry like i was
growing up with i guess this definitely
tastes like the instant curry blox the
meat is pretty good he must have cooked
it for a while taste wise i think pretty
basic japanese curry like out of the box
you put a secret ingredient in it to
make it sweeter you mentioned it doesn't
even make anything stick out for me
honey
oh wow it's not because i tasted apple
it's a typical one to put minced apple i
can't detect that i think out of a 10
i'll give it seven like i could
definitely eat this again but i'm not
dying to have this curry ingredients are
so basic seven maybe something you know
a little more so it's more fun all right
this is probably like a seven it reminds
me of i guess like my old days
curry you could do so many things this
one actually i cooked this for the first
time i found wagyu oxtail so i'm like
hmm this must be good i use the spinach
from yesterday and also i just put
mushrooms onions carrots and potatoes oh
my love those are big ass carrots again
what is repeat one of the big-ass
carrots it looks really nice it looks
really clean and i see like a lot of
vegetables but i see no protein
whatsoever or very little of it it looks
healthy it looks like japanese curry
again
wait this is really freaking good
it's missing something like you have
something going on with it but it's just
not strong enough it's not what i want
when i'm thinking of curry all right so
there's beef in it the vegetables go
really well together this is like
definitely something that a guy didn't
make it's definitely soup it feels like
something like a mother would cook which
is really nice like it's like very homey
there's a lot of depth in the flavor i'd
rate this like 8.59 for me like
something that's 10 out of 10 would be
something that's like you know
it doesn't remind me of curry the other
one i like more this is like my meltdown
i don't know what i'm chewing on i think
it's wacky oxtail wait why goose would
be so expensive too because i learned
it's wagyu
i'm putting some six thousand dollars
it's expensive
out of respect for what you used i would
give it like a nine out of ten the taste
is really savory i wish there were a
little bit less vegetables and a little
bit more meat my mom would often make me
curry growing up japanese curry was kind
of the way she went with it i put my own
heart and soul into calling the
restaurant and ordering it today i
present a fine japanese style katsu
curry free-range chicken with a whole
wheat breaded crust just lightly fried
to perfection the nice bowl of hearty
rice and some pickled radish i actually
did the presentation and the plating
though i'm very proud of that first off
the bat the presentation looks really
nice looks like japanese curry to me
especially with the tonkatsu a little
messy i don't really want to touch the
rice because the vegetables don't seem
appealing let me see how the curry
actually tastes
this is very interesting taste it's
really sweet that is some dry chicken
the rice is undercooked too
that is really dry wow the curry itself
doesn't have much taste
it threw me off i'm not really into
sweet curry although i don't know what
the taste is like i don't want to keep
trying to find out the presentation was
really nice i thought it was going to be
better i'll give it like a 1.5 i would
actually cook the rice it doesn't remind
me it just tastes like gravy i'm gonna
give him a three i'm done touching it
this is the worst one by far i mean it
looks cute but not so good how would you
rate this out of ten
i feel like it's not curry i picked thai
curry korea as a whole not the biggest
fan of it so i hope this came out well
the main meat is gonna be chicken i have
potato with some carrots as well there's
a white onion in here that's all diced
up this garlic this ginger there's
coconut milk there's red curry paste
there's some lime juice for the acidity
it's a little thick right now i promise
it was more smooth before it kind of
looks like a child a little but i can
promise you the flavors there so don't
worry about the appearance right now
it's definitely not japanese curry so
i'm thinking it's like thai or indian
curry this is what i'm talking about
like it looks so unique it's like a red
i can't tell what kind of taste like i'm
really curious oh what is it chili this
definitely smells a little spicy it
smells good though i'm not gonna lie
i'm not really trying to describe it
it's not bad but i'll know if it's good
i'm like very neutral about this it
tastes really unique i wish it was a
little bit spicier because i like spicy
i think it's a little bit sweet and i'm
not into sweet cream there's a lot going
on here it tastes a lot of ginger a
group of people is having a rumble in my
mouth you know just
in a good way in an interesting way
better than boring right if you
presented this to me and you didn't tell
me that we were making curry i wouldn't
know this was curry final review i would
definitely give it like a five out of
ten a color and also the texture of the
meat is pretty good what i would do
better is maybe a little bit more spices
it just feels very flat right now to be
honest i don't know if i'm into the
taste it might be five you know like
this dish is good but i don't have this
like a curry vibe i probably rate this a
seven too i'd definitely eat this yeah i
feel like thai curry is a little bit
more like soupy in a sense this one has
a lot of big chunks to it that's why it
seems like a chili in a sense to me like
or like a stew definitely a seven all
right how are you guys feeling good
good okay so in last place unfortunately
with an average score of 1.8
we have eugene
in third place with an average score of
5.7 we have randall
in second place with an average score of
seven we have eric
and in first place winner seven point
eight subi yeah
it was really good
hers was definitely the best
[Music]
you